what are your thoughts on hollywood
stealing an unknown writer's idea
does this happen a lot i think i think
it happens a lot less than
people believe because like my old
writing partner and i used to say
we'd make more money off the lawsuit
than we would on the screenplay
you know go ahead and steal and you know
we'd be so pleasure
it'd be such a pleasure for you to steal
our idea that means it's something good
you know
but uh you writers do a writer asked me
like okay um what's this process of
copyright you know
before i let anybody read it i was like
okay
you can copyright the script it takes a
process it's money and
you know or you can register at the
guild or you know
some say that even by the mere existence
of creating it is a copyright so there's
all sorts of factors but
what i've read is that the copyright
would protect you more in court
but the thing with that is that you
never own the copyright of a screenplay
because the minute you sell it it
becomes a work for hire
so you always have to sign over the the
rights to the company
so that was given away a long time ago
um
in in guild negotiations that the writer
never owns a copy of the script
so you're it's okay to do that but
uh when you see uh on the cover it says
registered
wgaw number one two six five five by
five
you know that's just a dead giveaway of
like an amateur that's afraid of
of my stuff being stolen you know what i
mean
no no professional writes that on the on
the cover of script
i think professionals expect you to do
your due diligence
and what i think more the more chance of
something being stolen is a pitch
because that's an ether you know like i
i was saying bef
uh my writing partner and i would go on
these
these pitch fest you know that their
agent would send us on
to like 12 companies and we'd do the
same pitch
around town and at 2 o'clock we've got
with with this person
and our manager would ask us agent
manager go how did it go
and we'd say well it didn't they didn't
know their eyes didn't light up and they
go
okay maybe you should switch and change
this element so from the afternoon on
we changed a different version of of the
thing but
my point is it's all a living breathing
thing and so somebody could wake up the
next morning and go
now they might not be the exact pitch
but they
but let's say an element of and go you
know what i have an idea
and that works in what do you do about
that but you can't be
you can't be um that way where you think
everybody's gonna steal your stuff you
know it's just not
you can be smart and when when you send
out your script you should
keep track in a log or journal uh
or spreadsheet who's reading the script
every time out if you don't have an
agent manager who that's their job
you know obviously they'll know that
it'll be through an official channel but
somebody says oh yeah give me the script
i i work at a company
okay that goes down who read it when
because these are important things to
know who
you don't want to to send your you know
you want to know who's reading it that's
important too
because if it starts getting bad
feedback you never hear about it
and then suddenly things start being
like why why don't i get a meeting with
that company because people are talking
now
you know the old days would go in a
database and there'd be coverage in the
studio would not have the coverage and
you couldn't
you couldn't fool them because they go
oh yeah we read that
two years ago they're trying to pawn
that off on us again you know
so i wouldn't be too fearful of and
there was a few stories about outright
theft but i think it's so
i mean you can't be afraid
to send your stuff out you know and and
it's sort of an arrogant idea where it's
like well my idea is so genius
that they're gonna steal it like warner
brothers doesn't have enough amazing
ideas already
and yours might be the one they steal
but it'd be a good lawsuit
but that being said though don't be
irresponsible sending it out the log the
date the place
absolutely the address even oh yeah no
keep it all because you want to you want
to keep track
of who's reading your stuff you want to
keep in control of that
and that's why when writers post their
stuff like a script up on their
their web page i would say
don't do that you don't know who's
reading it you don't know who's stealing
your ideas right
you have no way of tracking that if
you're afraid of that
that's even worse because somebody's
just going to your website and i know
it's
it's a way to promote your stuff but
that's not the way
you know to have your full script on on
your your um your website for someone
just to read
who's reading it you know that's you
want to keep track of that
you